parmi les 48 pilotes internationaux
présents à ce concours ce week-end aux
clayes-sous-bois beaucoup ont sûrement
un jour rêvé d'être aux commandes d'un
avion de ligne mais leurs appareils à
eux ne mesure pas plus d'un mètre et
pèse entre 50 et 100 g lors d'un
concours d'aéromodélisme
chaque pilote effectue un ballet plein
d'émotions pendant trois minutes
l'avion épouses des notes de musique une
chorégraphie imposé ponctuée de
renversement et de cercle en tonneau de
toute beauté
chaque pilote doit dans le temps en
partie réalisé sa propre chorégraphie
avec la musique de son choix peut
inventer des figures pour impressionner
le public en espérant qu'ils apprécient
à côté des français champions du monde
par équipes
geffray concourt dans la catégorie
promotion il vole depuis cinq ans et
rencontrent pour la première fois ces
rois dr c'est un rêve parce que on les
voit sur les magazines etc
et hélas le fait de le croiser et de
discuter avec lui ma difficulté
sans surprise le champion du monde
autrichien gerd brachmann s'est imposé
dans les airs devant le guyancourt toile
nicolas qui tue licencié au club les
clés du ciel